tens of millions of americans vaccinated
for covett are getting new options for
booster shots the fda voted yesterday to
authorize booster shots for everyone
ages 18 and older who got the johnson
and johnson shot and also for seniors
and people at high risk who got the
modern vaccine pfizer's booster shot was
authorized last month the committee also
said it's okay to mix and match vaccines
nikki batiste has more on the plan that
still needs cdc approval
for millions of vaccinated americans an
extra dose of protection is imminent new
fda guidelines allow moderna recipients
65 and up to get a booster as well as
people at higher risk for covid due to
their health or working conditions the
agency also approved a booster for any
johnson and johnson recipient 18 or
older how do we decide
which vaccine to get is a booster i
think just like we said at the beginning
of vaccine rollout get whatever vaccine
you can get your hands on dr celine
gallander is an infectious disease
expert at new york university she says
while any booster is a good booster j j
recipients should consider a mix and
match approach the announcement comes as
the white house prepares for the
emergency use authorization of the
pfizer vaccine for children ages 5
through 11. its plan includes smaller
needles and doses with vaccines offered
in doctors offices pharmacies and
schools but with no shots offered at
mass vaccination sites authorization is
expected in early november as soon as
the vaccine is authorized by the fda we
will begin shipping millions of dotion
doses nationwide and new york has joined
the list of cities mandating
vaccinations for city workers offering
its 46 000 unvaccinated employees a 500
bonus if they get the shot in the next
10 days we've given people a lot of time
first in the voluntary phase then in the
vaccinate or test phase it's time to
keep moving
here in new york city while the police
and fire commissioners have supported
vaccine mandates the unions have vowed
to fight back if cleared by the cdc the
moderna and johnson and johnson boosters
could be available by tomorrow modernist
booster would be given as early as six
months after a second dose and jnj is
two months after her first dose nikki
thank you